Oh leather outside is frightful but the
fire is so since we've no place to go
let it snow let it snow let it snow
hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to the loosely associated
google feud christmas edition oh oh holy
[ __ ] I don't know how this relates but I
know that it's going to be a very very
wonderful Christmas themed episode
because I've got my Christmas hat and my
cold-weather cardigan which I love very
much so cozy so flappy and flowy so
delightful I could hide my shame from
all the [ __ ] answers that I'm gonna
prayer in this video so if you don't
know about Google Feud it works is kind
of like family feud autocomplete on
Google kind of does its job and you have
to guess what its gonna be but that's
not how I'm gonna play it because I'm an
idiot and if I tried to do it the right
way
it all comes out wrong and very
homoerotic can you milk a president can
you milk anything with a nipple can you
sell your family's organs can you sell
your organs eggs sperm plasma can pigs
eat anything poop garbage nope what
party parts get you fill with bees what
body parts can you harvest from Grandma
I'm so sorry grandma what body parts can
you afford to lose is my cat gay my cat
Eris is my cat secretly Barbara Bush no
sneaking suspicion you fish ever
remember the matrix do fish ever fly do
fish ever dream about eating my face the
poor
for for judge you the poor should fill
in the crack the portion the portion
move to Detroit
oh no recipe for disaster
oh come on recipe for baby your mom
penguins are murderers paying winter
conspiring
conspiring against us penguins are the
Illuminati do all celebrities have a
bodyguard whoa
got one Tom Hanks is everybody Tom Hanks
his in my closet Tom Hanks is trapped in
my basement I'm trying to tell you guys
something about Tom eggs Tom axis robbed
a how wet weather in Idaho is snowy
weather in my pants is balmy weather in
your mom's house is hot heavy so so
silent it's better when it's wetter Star
Wars is oh sorry sir Wars Star Wars is
real Star Wars is fake
Star Wars is a little okay Star Wars is
dead
Star Wars is aa soares is a religion
[ __ ] skit Star Wars is gay Star Wars is
gay come on gong-gong controls what
comedy is that whatever good bad fake
gay oh geez
all right people dad's home dad's brunch
dad smoking closet did dad's private
you know dad's private morning-time
people my mom then that time is it wrong
my mom is my third cousin mom my baby
Oh No I shoulda said something days
about my mom I hate the taste you seem
uh I used to be one eye I lied I lied
about my MA I love my mom but in this
context it sounds bad
I love my dad I love my brother I love
my sister always brother nothing there
and why sisters oh I I love my dog I
love my cat [ __ ] how to raise raise your
IQ how to raise a proper gentleman huh
how to race in 1962 Mustang how to make
a human centipede how to make an
aardvark oh oh
how to make my sorry I think my mom is a
spy here to say I think my mom is a
doppelganger
I sold all my dignity I sold all my
record collections I sold all my tattoos
are the demons trying to get out tattoos
are cool [ __ ] pictures of the Loch
Ness monster pictures of boobs pictures
of ticks oh nope how do you get fun here
how do you get smarter how do you get
bigger do birds die do birds cry too
purse why should I fix my raging
erection should i pierce my ha ha ha why
are the friends so FUBU be why the
French explode has a dog ever been as
smart as a human has a dog ever been
able to reproduce with a human nope okay
is it easy to grow facial hair is it
easy to grow a beard is easy to grow
weed okay
do cats and dogs [ __ ] do cats and dogs
do cats and dogs who cats and dogs play
poker do cats and dogs visit their
grandparents do they they need to be
more responsible when is it a good time
to commit an act of eco-terrorism when
is it a good time true the Vietnam
flashback when is it a good time to to
scream my nipples off what if I ate my
legs what my grandma what if I ate my
house how old do I have to be to work at
YMCA dad the CIA at the Army why do men
have nipples
why do men pee standing up why do man
have erections why do men decide you
love Oh why'd why does my heart feel
like beads
why does my arm always get stuck sorry
to my mom inside my grandma oh oh wait
is my arm keep falling of my cat's
conscientious objector use why are cats
conspiring against us why are kids
naturally attracted to who does see
there we go Christmas one does
ah [ __ ] I can't think no don't think of
penis not not penis don't think about
his huge penis ah no don't can't do that
cuz this is how it all ties into
Christmas this is literally the only
opportunity I have to actually make it's
about Christmas and it is it's Christmas
it is to Santa Claus have days off does
Santa Claus have a wife ah
nailed it does Santa Claus have children
mmm have an e what shittaka like
diabetes oh I can't play this key this
is why it took me so long to play this
again I just can't do it I can't serve
you always every single episode I do
this you guys are gonna have a lower and
lower opinion each time we go by and
then I ruin the relationship between my
mom and my crib oh where where does my
filter go because the longer I play this
the less filter I have just a road
through and the most insane things pop
up to the forefront of my brain but
maybe that's what you like about it
maybe that'd be good
but either way thank you everybody so
much for watching let me know what you
thought down the comments below and as
always I will see you in the next video
bye bye
[Music]